♪ ♪
>> Chris: JOE BIDEN’S CAMPAIGN
SEIZED THE MOMENT THIS WEEK
USING THE WOODWARD BOOK TO TRY
AND CHANGE THE SUBJECT ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL FROM LAW AND
ORDER TO THE PANDEMIC.
RUNNING US NOW IS BIDEN CAMPAIGN
SENIOR POLICY ADVISOR, JAKE
SULLIVAN.
JAKE, JOE BIDEN HAS BLISTERED
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S HANDLING OF
THE CORONAVIRUS, ESPECIALLY IN
THE WAKE OF THE NEW BOOK ON THE
REVELATIONS IN THAT, BUT I WANT
TO FOCUS FIRST ON JOE BIDEN’S
RECORD IN THE EARLY DAYS OF THE
PANDEMIC.
ON JANUARY 27TH, BIDEN WROTE
THIS FOR "USA TODAY."
"I AM CONCERNED THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION’S SHORTSIGHTED
POLICIES HAVE LEFT US UNPREPARED
FOR A DANGEROUS EPIDEMIC THAT
WILL COME SOONER OR LATER."
BUT THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS
HOLDING MASS RALLIES AS LATE AS
MARCH 9TH AFTER THE CDC HAD
ALREADY WARNED AGAINST THOSE
KINDS OF GATHERINGS.
HOW COME?
>> Jake: WELL, FIRST, CHRIS,
YOU ARE RIGHT TO POINT OUT THAT
JOE BIDEN WAS MORNING THAT WE
WERE DANGEROUSLY UNPREPARED FOR
A PANDEMIC IN JANUARY, AND IN
FEBRUARY HE WAS WARNING THAT
CHINA WAS BLOCKING THE ACCESS
FOR OUR CDC INSPECTORS TO GET ON
THE GROUND TO BE ABLE TO LEARN
ABOUT THE VIRUS AND PROTECT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHILE
DONALD TRUMP WAS PRAISING THE
TRANSPARENCY.
AND IN MARCH, HE WAS LAYING OUT
COMPREHENSIVE PLANS FOR HOW WE
WOULD DEAL WITH THIS.
>> Chris: I WANTED -- CAN YOU
ANSWER MY QUESTION?
WHY WAS HE HOLDING MASS RALLIES
AS LATE AS MARCH 9TH?
>> Jake: BECAUSE HE WASN’T THE
PRESIDENT AND HE DIDN’T GET THE
INFORMATION FROM GOVERNMENT
EXPERTS TELLING HIM THIS WAS
DEADLY AND AIRBORNE THE WAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID.
IT WASN’T BEING TOLD BY HIS
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR WAY
THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS THAT THIS
WAS GOING TO BE THE WORST CRISIS
OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
HE DIDN’T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
KIND OF INFORMATION THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAD AND
DONALD TRUMP GOT ALL THAT
INFORMATION, LEARNS THE VIRUS
WAS DEADLY, LEARNED IT WAS
AIRBORNE, LEARNED IT WAS WORSE
THAN THE FLU, AND THEN LIED TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND DID
NOTHING ABOUT IT.
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
RECORD BETWEEN DONALD TRUMP AND
JOE BIDEN IN THIS REGARD.
>> Chris: WELL, LET’S TALK
ABOUT ANOTHER DIFFERENCE IN
THEIR RECORD.
ON JANUARY 31ST, PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS ON
CHINA.
THAT SAME DAY, HERE IS WHAT
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD TO SAY.
>> THIS IS NO TIME FOR
DONALD TRUMP’S RECORD OF
HYSTERIA, XENOPHOBIA, HYSTERICAL
XENOPHOBIA, AND FEARMONGERING,
TO LEAD THE WAY INSTEAD OF
SCIENCE.
>> Chris: BIDEN DENIES THAT HE
WAS TALKING THAT DAY ABOUT THE
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAD JUST IMPOSED.
ARE WE TO BELIEVE IT WAS JUST A
COINCIDENCE, THAT HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT XENOPHOBIA THE DAY THAT
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS ON CHINA?
>> Jake: WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
CHRIS, INDEPENDENT FACT-CHECKERS
INCLUDING POLITIFACT HAVE LOOKED
AT THE CLAIM THAT JOE BIDEN WAS
OPPOSED TO THE CHINA TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS AND THEY HAVE
DEEMED THAT CLAIM FALLS.
IT’S NOT A COINCIDENCE JOE BIDEN
WAS TALKING ABOUT DONALD TRUMP’S
RECORD FROM THE BEGINNING OF
DEMONIZING CHINESE-AMERICANS, OF
GIVING NAMES TO THIS VIRUS, OF
RAISING QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
WE SHOULD TRUST ASIAN-AMERICANS.
THIS IS SOMETHING DONALD TRUMP
HAS BEEN DOING OVER THE COURSE
OF HIS FOUR YEARS, USING
XENOPHOBIA AND FEARMONGERING IN
THE MOMENT OF CRISIS RATHER THAN
ACTUALLY DOING HIS JOB.
WHAT JOE BIDEN SAID WAS THAT
THESE TRAVEL BANDS CAN SLOW THE
VIRUS, BUT THEY CAN’T STOP THE
VIRUS, AND THAT’S WHAT THE
RECORD REFLECTS.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THERE WERE
RESTRICTIONS PUT IN PLACE, BOTH
WITH RESPECT TO CHINA AND
EUROPE, WE HAVE 200,000 PEOPLE
DEAD AND 6 MILLION CASES AND THE
REASON WHY IS THAT DONALD TRUMP
DIDN’T DO HIS JOB, WITH RESPECT
TO TESTING --
>> Chris: I WANT TO FOCUS
AGAIN ON THIS -- JAKE, I WANT TO
FOCUS ON THIS BECAUSE YOUR
CAMPAIGN -- YOUR CAMPAIGN DIDN’T
SAY -- YOU SAY WELL, THE
FACT-CHECKERS SAY HE DIDN’T
OPPOSE IT.
YOUR CAMPAIGN DIDN’T SAY THAT
BIDEN APPROVED OF THE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS UNTIL APRIL.
WHY DID IT TAKE HIM SO LONG?
AND WOULD YOU AGREE THAT THE
PRESIDENT MOVING SO MUCH FASTER,
JANUARY 31ST, TO IMPOSE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS WHEN BIDEN DIDN’T
FORMALLY COME OUT IN SUPPORT OF
THE RESTRICTIONS UNTIL
APRIL 3RD, THE TRUMPS ACTIONS
SAVED THOUSANDS OF LIVES?
>> Jake: FIRST OF ALL, CHRIS,
THE VIRUS WAS ALREADY IN THE
UNITED STATES BY THE TIME HE
IMPOSED THESE RESTRICTIONS.
>> Chris: I’M ASKING YOU A
SPECIFIC QUESTION.
I’M ASKING YOU A SPECIFIC
QUESTION.
WHY DID IT TAKE BIDEN TWO MONTHS
TO APPROVE THE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS?
>> Jake: WELL, FIRST, IT
DIDN’T TAKE HIM TWO MONTHS.
IN A SPEECH ON MARCH 12TH
JOE BIDEN SAID THE TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS CAN SLOW THE VIRUS,
BUT THEY CAN’T STOP THE VIRUS.
HIS WHOLE POINT WAS THE ONLY WAY
LONG-TERM FOR US TO GET THIS
VIRUS UNDER CONTROL IS FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO STAND UP AND DO HIS
JOB HERE AT HOME WHERE THE VIRUS
WAS CIRCULATING.
THAT’S WHAT HE WAS PLACING SO
MUCH EMPHASIS ON THE KINDS OF
THINGS OTHER COUNTRIES DID TO
GET THE VIRUS UNDER CONTROL.
TESTING, PPE, RESOURCES.
ALL THINGS DONALD TRUMP DIDN’T
DO SO THAN ON FRIDAY OF THIS
WEEK, MORE THAN A THOUSAND
AMERICANS DIED IN CANADA, ZERO
DID.
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE IN FAILED
LEADERSHIP IN THE UNITED STATES
AND THE KIND OF EFFECTIVE
LEADERSHIP THAT JOE BIDEN WOULD
HAVE BROUGHT TO BEAR HEAD EVEN
PRESIDENT DURING THIS CRISIS.
>> Chris: I WANT TO ABOUT
ANOTHER TOPIC BECAUSE JOE BIDEN
HAS BEEN HITTING PRESIDENT TRUMP
HARD ON THE LAW AND ORDER.
SO THAT WILL BE THREATENED IF
JOE BIDEN -- IN PORTLAND,
OREGON, SEE THE VIDEOS HERE,
MORE THAN 100 DAYS OF PROTESTS,
OFTEN VIOLENT.
DOES THE PRESIDENT THINK THE
MAYOR OF THAT CITY AND THE
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE HAVE
HANDLED THE HUNDRED DAYS OF
PROTESTS AND RIOTS IN PORTLAND
PROPERLY?
>> Jake: YOU SAID DOES THE
PRESIDENT BELIEVE THAT?
DOOM IN THE VICE PRESIDENT.
>> Chris: IF I SAID THAT I
MEANT VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> Jake: VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN
BELIEVES THAT THE SINGLE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SUCCESS AND
FAILURE WITH RESPECT TO SAFETY
IN THESE COMMUNITIES HAS BEEN
DONALD TRUMP, NOT THE LOCAL
LEADERSHIP.
IT HAS BEEN DONALD TRUMP POURING
GASOLINE ON THE FIRE AND CAUSING
MORE DAMAGE, MORE WRECKAGE, MORE
DIVISION, MORE VIOLENCE,
INCITING HIS SUPPORTERS FOR
EXAMPLE TO DRIVE CONVOYS OF THE
STREET, FIRING PAINTBALL AND
SPRAYING PEPPER SPRAY ON
PROTESTERS.
THAT’S WHAT JOE BIDEN WANTS TO
STOP.
>> Chris: JAKE, IT’S UP TO THE
MAYOR TOOK ALL OF THE POLICE
FORCE.
THE GOVERNOR TO CALL OUT THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
DON’T THEY BEAR SOME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE HUNDRED
DAYS?
CAN YOU REALLY SAY IT’S
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN WASHINGTON
WAS CALLING ALL THE PROTESTS --
MORE IMPORTANT IN FAILING TO
STOP THE PROTESTS.
>> Jake: OF COURSE
RESPONSIBILITY LODGES AT EVERY
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT, LOCAL,
STATE, ET CETERA, BUT CHRIS,
HERE’S THE IMPORTANT POINT.
IF THERE WERE DEMOCRATIC MAYORS
AND A DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR IN
PORTLAND AND IN PORTLAND AND
OREGON WHEN JOE BIDEN WAS
VICE PRESIDENT AND YOU DIDN’T
SEE THIS HAPPENING.
JOE BIDEN AND BARACK OBAMA
PROTECTED FEDERAL PROPERTY
WITHOUT HAVING TO SEND IN
MILITIAS.
JOE BIDEN AND BARACK OBAMA CUT
THE VIOLENT CRIME RATE BY 15% IN
THIS COUNTRY WITHOUT INCITING
MORE LAWLESSNESS AND MORE CHAOS
AND MORE VIOLENCE ON THE
STREETS.
SO THE REAL DIFFERENCE IN WHAT
WE ARE SEEING TODAY IS A
DIFFERENCE IN LEADERSHIP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT CHOOSES TO
INFLAME EVERY SITUATION RATHER
THAN TRY TO CALM THEM DOWN.
>> Chris: THE CORONAVIRUS, THE
FACT THAT --
[INDISCERNIBLE].
DON’T YOU THINK THE FACT THAT WE
FED GEORGE FLOYD AND REACTION OF
THAT, DON’T YOU THINK THAT’S
PLAYED A ROLE IN IT?
AGAIN, COULD YOU REALLY BLAME
ALL THIS ON PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> Jake: OF COURSE.
OF COURSE.
THE POINT THAT I’M MAKING IS
THAT AT A MOMENT LIKE THIS IN A
CRISIS MOMENT LIKE THIS, THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
NEED FROM THE WHITE HOUSE IS AN
EFFORT TO REDUCE TENSION, TO
CALM THE SITUATION DOWN, TO CALL
OUT VIOLENCE WHEREVER IT COMES
FROM AND FRANKLY, DONALD TRUMP
HAS SIMPLY BEEN UNWILLING TO
CALL OUT -- JOE BIDEN HAS SAID
WHETHER IT’S FROM THE LEFT OR
RIGHT VIOLENCE IS WRONG.
DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN TOO SCARED
TO DO THAT BECAUSE HE DOESN’T
WANT TO TAKE ON HIS OWN PEOPLE.
I’M NOT SITTING HERE SAYING THAT
EVERY LAST ASPECTS OF THIS FALLS
AT THE FEET OF THE WHITE HOUSE,
OF COURSE NOT.
BUT WHAT I AM SAYING IS THAT ONE
OF THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN HOW THINGS OPERATED
UNDER THE OBAMA-BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND HOW THEY
OPERATE IN DONALD TRUMP’S
AMERICA IS THAT WE HAVE
LEADERSHIP IN THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT IS POURING GASOLINE ON THE
FIRE RATHER THAN TRYING TO BRING
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF PROGRESS
TOWARDS GREATER SAFETY IN OUR